thoughts on current military law
enforcement
self-defense techniques and what you
both would incorporate to make
better
that's a super broad question
you know i'll narrow it down okay
and i've talked about a little bit on
the podcast but
you got cops police
who have a hard job miserable
i could never do it never would want to
do it what'd you say to me yeah
dre i mean just dealing with the dregs
of society
you know for 14 calls and then the 15th
call you're going to
you know some domestic violence and i
mean just it's just a horrible
hard job and then you have these
shootings where quote unquote innocent
people get shot and sometimes they are
i mean some of these police shootings
there's no way i can approve it
and i am all about killing bad guys
and some of the shootings you just say
man that cop and i always look at it the
same way and i say
that cop didn't have the training
training he needed
i i what really hurts is that i know how
to
i know what to do to make them better
and get them better at that i know you
do i don't have the money they don't
have the time they know the money they
don't have the time
a lot of times they don't even have the
experience within the department of
someone that knows how to train people
mentally because that's what it is it's
mental preparation
of getting someone ready to handle these
scenarios
because it's just an unknown scenario
that's what it is and one of my
worst examples is this guy pulls up to a
7-eleven it's all it's all body camera
the guys the whole thing's on video
the guy gets a call there's a guy with a
gun in 7-11 pulls up in his cruiser the
7-eleven gets out of his car
sees a guy walking away starts yelling
at him the guy's wearing a hoodie
the guy's walking away from him he's the
cops yelling at him freeze breeze breeze
the guy doesn't freeze and finally he's
yelling and he's standing the cop
standing in the
wide open holding his gun out yo please
please and finally the guy turns around
looks at the cop
reaches his hands in his pockets boom
cop shoots him guy falls down falls the
curb
rolls he's on his stomach cop comes over
rolls him over starts to search him he
finds pulls his head off pulls his hood
off
he's got headphones in reaches in his
pockets he's got an iphone on
and he was just sitting there listening
to music couldn't hear the cop turned
around
reaching his pocket to turn off the
iphone and you know the cop
who got the call there was a guy with a
gun and thinks he's reaching for a gun
dusts him yeah guy died blood out and
you can hear the cop the cop felt
horrible
you know once he realized that he's like
come on buddy it's gonna be okay i'm
gonna get you just like
the classic things that i know you've
heard before of like i want to save this
guy's life
and it's not gonna happen yeah and what
i know is that that guy
going into that situation from the
get-go
if you think someone's got a gun don't
stand out in the open and talk to him
get behind cover and stand back and you
know stay behind your car get on your
cruiser
get on your loudspeaker and look at him
and watch him and see what he's doing
and see if there's a real threat but
don't expose yourself to him by standing
out in the middle of the open
where if he does have a gun he's going
to get you yeah
and those are simple things that you
know you could do to improve the
training what you have to do is you have
to put people in stressful situations
during the training
and that's what we did in the seal teams
i know that's what you guys do in the sf
is you get put in these horrible
stressful situations where everything is
getting destroyed you're getting shot
with paintball and
they're blowing smoke grenades up and
all frags hitting you they do that
in the training so when you get in
combat you're not freaked out yeah and
you can handle the situation
train hard so you bleed less you know
it's like it's pretty simple
and uh but we we do in austin
we do a stress test a week sometimes
it's barbell stuff on the range and kit
where we're doing like olympic lifts to
a sprint and then you pick up your gun
and shoot
um or it's slung and you do like a five
mile run
and as soon as you step on the range
it's like 500 targets you're just
running down the line and that's so
i know and it feels normal for my heart
rate to be pounding so that i can't hear
anything besides my own beating
heart in my ears sweat dripping in my
eyes sweat dripping on my optics my grip
being
jacked up because it's covered with
sweat and you know a little bit of blood
because i
tripped and fell on my face you know
like and that seems normal
if i went to a range and shot in like a
vacuum
you know like where it's like
air-conditioned right and like you guys
like all right
um no you can't shoot faster than one
round a second and no drawing from the
holster
so let's just you know have a good time
here i wouldn't know what to do
right i'd be like this is really
uncomfortable um can someone just start
screaming at me and throwing something
at me so i could just at least
shoot you know 100 um the training for
my my brother's police officer my dad's
a police officer i went to the police
academy in 99
and i was astounded i was a kid i was 21
years old
i was astounded at how they were not
prepared for anything
one was like all right how about this
all 20 of you
try to get cuffs on me yeah
didn't happen no no my wrists were
bloody you know i had a cuff on my leg
i had one cuff on my arm and i had like
six or seven of them cuffed together and
there was like
there's like 18 or there's 12 of them
yet left and
they didn't know what to do you know
this is a 21 year old kid yeah it's not
their fault
just like you said they just don't have
the training yeah
with that said if a cop tells you to get
on the ground
get on talk to him about it later under
i get it like you're you know the
constitution so well and you're like the
greatest
lawyer about you know legal criminology
shut up lay down get on top and just
figure it out later or have your lawyer
do it if you can't afford a lawyer just
have talked to sergeant afterwards
yeah just give those guys more training
and you got to do the right kind of
training you got to do the
i think you got to do force on force
man-on-man training when was the last
time the
municipal police department did a force
on force training you should be doing it
all the time
all the time i've never even heard of a
department doing it that's horrible
sim serta whatever i mean whatever
whatever you're going to use
but you got to have people humans other
humans that are maneuvering on you
that are reacting to you that are
drawing on you or they're not or they're
raising their hands or they're pulling
out their cell phone
or they're running scared so when you
did force on force in the seals
um who do you use as your opt for seals
the other seals dude
and is there nothing better than i mean
who wants to win
everybody everybody wants to win so like
we at fort bragg would use like 82nd
airborne or would use another sf group
dude and that's i mean if there are any
second guy like this is their chance
they're gonna do
everything that they can to shoot an sf
guy
you know and if it's if it's another sf
guy then
the the level of competition that
competitive nature like oh i'm gonna i'm
gonna we're gonna do i'm gonna ambush
them we're gonna crawl up into the
ventilation and try to shoot them in the
top of their heads from the
from the air conditioning you know
they're like taking quickie saws and
cutting
the ventilation open i mean it's
gangster it's gangster and you know what
that's what's what's great about that is
guess what the enemy does the same thing
what the mousse does they're just not as
good
they build false walls they build trap
trap doors they do all that stuff
and i i was had a had a group
that was going through their land
warfare training in the seal teams
and they actually failed and so we were
retreading them making go
making them go through it again go
through their ftx's their field training
exercises these big
giant training exercises with all kinds
of chaos
and they were doing their first re
retread so they're trying to
pass the exercise this time and i go out
there and i'm listening to their brief
and i'm watching them to do the
rehearsal and they get done with
rehearsal
and they all come together and the the
senior enlisted guy is kind of putting
out some word
and he looks at me and he goes hey
jacquard you got anything to say to
these guys
and i wasn't really expecting it you
know so i said you know this is 40 40
man seal element i said
yeah i got something to say you guys are
gonna go out there
against six other guys there's 40 of you
you guys got machine guns grenades and
there's
40 of you i said go out there and when
they start shooting at you
hunt those [ __ ] down and murder
them
they're like yeah yeah and so the
troop walks away and they're all fired
up
and then the the senior enlisted guy and
the senior officer standing there and
they said hey man
thanks for thanks for you know getting
our guys fired up i think that really
helped him out
and i said you should hear what i'm
about to go tell
my guys which was my guys that we're
gonna go against him yeah cause i would
give my guys all kinds of rewards
anybody that they could kill
they would capture bodies anybody could
get a perimeter they would just
completely what you're saying they would
completely mud suck them
and draw them into the most chaotic
situations and the point of all this
conversation
is that you're going against other human
beings and other human beings
that are going to do unpredictable
things and that's what makes the
training challenging and that's what
makes life challenging that's what makes
these situations challenging in a real
scenario is you don't know what these
people are going to do how many how many
times you've been dealing with some
you know enemy or or unknown and you're
like what in god's name is this person
doing iraq or afghanistan i didn't i
didn't fight in afghanistan but iraq
you'd be
looking at someone going oh this person
is insane yeah what are they doing right
now
why are they doing that they're gonna
die if they you know it's just it's
crazy yeah that's the thing about humans
is they're humans
you know there's like points of
departure from logic you know and they
live in chaos and some people can't even
live without chaos and then we're going
into a place where
cultures are different languages are
different you know what is the norm is
different
and we're trying to enact what we think
is normal
and they're like bro you're you're crazy
i'm like no no you're crazy you're like
no
yeah it's all poor cops yeah
so and you know what you can do if
you're a cop though and you don't your
force doesn't have the
the money for this so they're not doing
this you can absolutely train you can
actually
absolutely train in jiu jitsu in mma in
fighting
so you get more comfortable and more
confident in those situations
and the other thing i've said to do in
the past is man uh yeah i know it sounds
lame
but watch some youtube videos watch some
youtube videos of these
of like the thing that i just described
watch that youtube video and say i watch
youtube videos
in combat and before combat you know
what i watch before youtube i watch war
movies but
documentaries yeah so i could watch
these guys in action and get
see what was happening in their faces
because you can watch people on youtube
watch these perpetrators
and start to understand human nature
better just by watching
what they're doing just grow your mind
grow your brain a little bit
and if you want to get better at
shooting dry fire yeah
i spend 90 of my my practice time of
shooting um without bullets in my gun
you know and there's like a few grand
masters that are out shooting me right
now
yeah so dry fire yeah